get out and move away from the vehicle  stay cold be  what's going on now take it down run no  don't run  do not run giraffe  I'm a child of the 80s I grew up playing  with the Transformers action figures I  grew up watching the animated series  when transformers hit I was right in the  middle  I vividly remember a transforming  Optimus Prime it's awesome to go back  and see where bumblebee came from we had  all decided we were going back to the  80s so we went back to the gen one  characters well going back to my  experience as a kid Autobots were always  cars Decepticons were always aircraft  we're simplifying and squaring things  out  like the toy and it conjures up that g1  aesthetic every detail we could get off  the cartoon we applied to the characters  it's great that it's headed back to the  beginning set in a time period where I  first fell in love with transformers  you  you